gruppe umwelt und naturkatastrophen oder
einer pandemie wir sind bestmöglich
ausgebildet und ausgerüstet
mein zwillingsbruder ist formel 1
gerückt weil sich dann entschlossen beim
bundesheer dabei zu bleiben und ich habe
mal acht ich möchte zumindest uns
infrage überholen und sage ich dann im
endeffekt ortschaft letztes jahr als er
nach gezogen ist auch wachtmeister
gerade die arbeitsmappe seine materie um
was sich natürlich sehr schnell
verändert immer neue sachen dazu kommen
was will eigentlich nie langweilig
der abwehr-star um atomare biologische
oder chemische gefahrstoffe oder
kampfmittel abwehren zu können
beziehungsweise um sie zu
dekontaminieren
in folge bedeutet dass man eben diesen
raum so sauber wieder hinbekommt was.de
mental normales leben
von seiten der bande mit sind ja auch
eingesetzt worden um schulen und andere
wichtige räumlichkeiten wieder so
hinzubekommen dass der normale betrieb
weitergehen kann
ich möchte menschen gern helfen
ist die arbeit sehr abwertend und für
sich eine der waffengattungen
auch wenn sie mal wirklich brenzlig wird
doch einsatzbereiche hat die auch im
zivilen verwendung finden